- Well, tell us about
your time in the military.
You served for, was it nearly 17 years?
- 17 and a half total time in service.
I had 10 and a half active duty.
(audience cheers, applauds)
- Oh, wow.
- But yeah, I was with the
82nd Airborne, the 101st.
Had the great privilege of working
with some of the greatest
people in the world.
- Yeah, wow, well, so
even though you're retired
from the military, you say
that that training kinda
never goes away, right?
- That's a fact, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I say this from my stage every night
when we're on stage, and I
use the term once a soldier,
always a soldier, and it is the truth.
- Yeah.
- It's just something
that never gets away from you.
- Yeah.
- All of these people can attest that.
No matter what they do
in their future lives,
wherever they may end up,
what they're doing right now
will be with them forever,
and those relationships,
which is also a wonderful thing.
- Yeah!
- They never go away.
- I hope not for them.
So you're very popular with the military.
I'm sure they connect with you
because obviously,
you're a veteran as well,
but why do you think your
songs hit them so deeply?
'Cause people love you.
- I wished I knew.
(both laughing)
- Then you'd know the secret. (laughs)
- I think it's because I sing and write
from their perspective, really.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
like I said, I'm a soldier.
I entertain people now.
I sing, and I write
songs, produce records,
get to be in movies, which is why I'm.
For the record, any of you.
- I love this!
- People making fun of this,
thinking I'm not clean-shaven
like I normally am.
Like I said, I think it's
because I'm still them,
and like you, we're still fans.
- Yeah.
- So when I sing and write,
I try to sing from that perspective,
as if I wanted to hear the song.
- Absolutely; sometimes
I write to something
that I wanna hear that'll
help me kinda heal,
and that's why I do it.
- Yeah.